siamo qui riuniti per una grande
giornata ma sta per proseguire con i
migliori dei suoi gusti con i più grandi
con il bellissimo tutte stelle che ti
fanno onore blog numero 18 feb e morto
ieri dicesse note 17 anche ok risolte al
30 softblog numero 17 questa è una
curiosità e il riscontrato un pochino le
tante persone meno richiesti in
tarantino sarà succede in un set dal
momento che mi trovo in milano
a riportarvi con me con 7 e in questo
caso condividerò con rocco siffredi
ci sono tantissime figure professionali
tantissime poi le persone che lavorano
in uno con rocco cosa succede si può
riprendere
cioè sono professionisti comunque
tranquillo appena giunta voce che
guglielmo e molto professionale sugli
altri sette cosa che non è sul suo
canale di youtube
spiegaci guglielmo capito di essere
professore quando lavoro con
professionisti poter adottare
rubagalline cerco comunque di mettermi
al loro livello per non farli sentire a
disagio perché abbiamo le zampe palmate
risultare tra i peracottaro alle
rubagalline io vorrei fare la rubandogli
se non ti offendi siamo pronti ad
entrare giorno stiamo aspettando tampone
però al momento c'è il rocco la prima
volta che mi dicono che con rocco il
tampone si fa uno alla volta però
aspetto il mio turno che dire quanto
vale anche avevano narici così ecco qua
perfetto no bellissima la sofferenza
tanto mentre la linea ma subito a
provarci sul set di tante naturale poche
ore di sonno come sempre
[Musica]
ma ci vorrebbe un miracolo per guglielmo
stare un attimo la mascherina vediamo o
perfetto grazie ma nel caso in cui nel
succo si sbagliasse qualcosa cosa si
utilizza tipo il correttore no quelle
cose lì ecco i parchi dove tutti un
fatto il bagno poi parla mentre sta
truccando per cancellare ma niente premi
ci vuole una bella preghiera particolare
dall'asilo sentito in silenzio i
migliori master rendini fantastico
aspetta se voi ci penso io è quel red tv
o perfetto ma sto spiegando io come
funziona
che rianima quello libero di mettere
sulla testa molto la mano c'è un
brevetto il retto guglielmo che la mano
si scalda e poi si mette un targa del
veicolo prima che lasci lavorare
non stiamo qui a pettinare le bambole
guglielmo lascia fare a mani esperte ti
prego questo ricciolo la mossa della
sacca si augura che è successo
[Applauso]
ma perché questa cosa perché così non è
più lenta la la nuova tecnica arriva
dalla sand vabbè che dica arrivata a los
angeles azionista
ma che razza di sette questo che senso
non c è tardi
no no allora non ci intere famiglie si è
duro nel senso comunque solido questo
set amica strom in una piscina e dove ci
ha portato a cosa pensava di vedere
enrico mi sono detto andiamo in un certo
con rocco ma che siete piedi magari se
sei fortunato ma dimmi se il momento di
disegnare adesso s'è girato e team aqua
turno prima di essere a 90 gradi di
capitano in un segmento 1500 da questi
di vanity vero set porno questa la [ __ ]
ma la speranza è che siedono nel mio
stile
partiamo subito tornati oggi
al tema di oggi sicuramente ne parleremo
ma ci sta passando un elicottero però
per fare queste chiacchierate non ho
bisogno di un altro
ora ti conosciamo tutti quanti
cominciano a pensare subito l'immagine
molto belle e romantiche quindi devi
sapere che io dai 12 ottimo lavoro
grazie grazie che stai portando
prestigio a questo canale perché
veramente guglielmo è un mentre tende
era nella tappa meno male che ci abbiano
loro adesso come seriosità oggi ha mai
fatto condoni stofile così poi ho visto
ho detto mirow oggi mi sa che partono
lascerà il momento perché riporta una
pausa pranzo katherine
e vicino ti si è l'immagine della
finisce ici rilanci per fare miss però
già fatto un bel piattone è bello carico
in fatto di turismo perché ne voglio due
marocco dove cioè è giustamente lievi o
a livello proprio pratico una posizione
della quale aveva parlato rocco e
fantasia il signore degli anelli
3 tutti quanti cioè non si può aiutare a
meglio quale ci stavo chiedendo
efficiente come si fa vediamolo
direttamente della curiosità ma come si
fa a livello fisico in tre come si
incastrano molto facile ma non crediamo
molto facile il creato per bere sdraiata
sindoni ovvero la cugina cosa più
genuina macchina quindi un'altra band ha
suonato in giro e curiamo la faceva base
o preveduto mio curriculum vitae ragazza
male antico che facile stanno facendo la
conta si tira l'altro deve andare a ben
nove regioni abbiano siate avanti guarda
che il semplice
facciamola live dai
piedi si presta però che mi permette la
regia sono temi su cui divanetti viveur
confortanti qui si possono fare tre
versioni voglio fare un film con te
dell'oie lavinia tu hai trovato il modo
per rimandare a [ __ ] guglielmo ciao
io mi dimetta lui io pensavo che rocco
ci facessi chiudere il canale ma più che
questa medaglia e da certi sexy e come
tagliare ryan ti prego ti prego ma che
sta facendo
guglielmo dormendo guarda metti la punta
del flec sono la forza vele m
bussano alla porta che è così non petro
bussato alla porta che ma vuoi dire
qualcosa sono scuse
[Musica]
perché io dopo questa scena mini senzio
per le ormai sapranno l'industria del
porno che preferisco poi posso mettere
una buona parola come una delle due
ragazze francesi che tu sei complice lo
dai
è proprio una delle sue ragazze francese
dove la vita non è niente ma ragazzi
serve mercato una mano con un buon caffè
un caffè perché no ma non è che avete un
posto più che guglielmo savi
per ogni anno viola c'è lo sa dipinti in
caso tagli profondi segnalano sentenza
ora nessuno sia assunti ho provato prima
con una legalità no no ho chiesto solo
per me la linea non sai che facciano mai
che non hanno bisogno ha detto questo lo
dici tu per tanto ai bisogni qualcuno
porti un caffè mondi tutto mi stanno
trovando il posto hai appena detto che
la fine è sul pezzo
ma guarda che anch'io la mia acqua si è
riscaldata bravi serve una mano grazie
niente volete acqua ha da tempo grazie
sia gentile da un 10 anche portarmi un
cappello
sì sì torno subito su questo posso
chiudere lui no no no no no mi hanno
detto guarda manca qualcuno impostazione
che hanno detto loro cosa hanno detto sì
sì sì sì sì da qualcuno impostazione
così mi hanno detto no la camera questa
parte residenza riso da dietro
stavo mettendo un po posto che sai e
hanno chiesto comunque di yo yo di como
a tuo fratello e cercando di farsi
assumere da loro
no non si tocca la cosa è costoso e noti
perché volevo dare una spolverata che
sia il caso in cui il caso in cui ti ho
mai detto che sto a fare i protocolli si
conterebbero assumere cose
come nei capelli stiamo imparando il
mestiere rubando con giochi di scusa non
tema stato rubarlo da me il mestiere ma
è anche stato un grande maestro per noi
a volte gli allegati prime ma non è
sicuramente il loro mai tirato fuori
contratto forte nonostante le doti per
lavoro abbandonarci davvero si sa chi è
andato il tempo stessi competiamo e
qualcuno l'ha assunta ci sta provando in
tutti i modi perché si voleva assumere
da rocco siffredi nel bene si
ribalteranno le situazioni sarò io il
suo agente
e lei la mia esmeralda questa giornata
marocco mi ha sfondato e vediamo domani
per lei 14 con un'altra puntata di
blogging anche un'altra puntata di vento